what's that believe nation today I'm
gonna talk about the seven stages that
each start up goes through to make their
first million dollars so get a lot of
entrepreneurs ask me questions about how
to make their first million dollars what
are the steps that companies go through
what are the stages that you need to
understand that most businesses of flow
through and so I thought I'd make this
video today sharing my thoughts on the
seven steps that companies go through on
their process and making their first
million dollars so step number one is
you have to have of dissatisfaction with
the status quo you have to not like
what's happening around you successful
entrepreneurs have a big dissatisfaction
with what's currently happening they're
not happy with the solutions they have a
problem either their own problem or
somebody else's problem and they're just
not happy with the current solutions out
there it's the start of every single
great business there has to be a pain
point and a dissatisfaction with the
current solutions out there
[Music]
number two is idea generation so we have
a problem our own problem a friend's
problem we're dissatisfied with the
solutions out there now we got to figure
out what's an idea that's going to work
what's the winning idea that combines
what we love to do what we're super
passionate excited about with what's
going to solve the problem and there may
be multiple ways to solve this problem
whatever problem you know you're facing
right now there could be a million
different ways to solve it but not all
of them are gonna work for you and not
all of them align with what you're
passionate about and so at the core of
every successful business is a
combination of what there's a need for
what there's dissatisfaction with what
pain point people have with what you are
super passionate and excited about and
combining those things will lead to a
successful idea to launch a business
with
[Music]
stage number three is you actually
launched your business and this is where
a lot of people fall down a lot of
people get stuck in just the idea
generation in the planning because it's
exciting to plan
it's exciting to plan and see how we can
build a multi-million dollar empire and
what our life would look like we get a
high from that we get a high even
thinking about what our life would look
like but then we actually have to do the
work and doing the work kind of sucks a
lot of the time most of the time and we
don't want to do that work because we
want to stay on that high planet we're
just imagining that future vision for
ourselves you have to start so many
people have great amazing ideas and they
see other people make money off of it
and you claim that that was your idea
well who cares if it was your idea they
had the idea to and they want to undid
something about it and so when you have
that great idea you need to actually
start where too many people die with
their best ideas still in them you need
to take action on the idea stage number
four is failure and adjustment a super
important thing to understand is most
businesses don't end up the way that
they planned the thing that actually
makes you money that has a big impact
that helps you explode is very rarely
the thing that you start with so it's
still important to have a plan it's so
important to have an idea of what you're
gonna do but recognizing that that plan
is likely going to fail so let's get it
out there as soon as possible and then
you need to adjust and tweak to what the
market wants and to what you're
passionate about to build something even
better it's super important most
companies you look at how they started
look at what their first product was and
look at what they sell now it's totally
different and they had the willingness
to fail and to adjust hewlett-packard
started selling audio oscillators for
films and they sold you know a couple
audio oscillators for films I don't even
know they still sell audio oscillators
it's not anywhere close to being a big
part of their business they adjusted
Wrigley's started off in the baking soda
or baking powder industry and as a side
they happen to give some gum away so
every case that you bought of their
baking sort of baking powder you would
get some gum with it people really like
the gums is that huh
why don't we focus on gum and then
Wrigley's became this big gum brain and
so part of success in any business is
recognizing that you need to get through
that phase that the great idea that you
have no matter how great it looks in
your head is not gonna be the one that
ultimately guides you to massive success
it'll be a seed and the seed will have
to grow and it will grow by testing the
idea by talking to customers by getting
in the market and then adjusting and too
many people make that mistake they
launch it doesn't work and then they
quit expect to launch expect it not to
work and then adjust fail and adjust
that will be your path through phase
number five is extending the idea this
is where a lot of entrepreneurs also
will fall down they'll have some initial
success with their business and now
we're talking about the path to being a
million dollar company to have some
initial success with their business but
they won't expand beyond it where it's
very rare that you could take one
product in one single market and build
up a million dollar multi-million dollar
company you need to start thinking how
do I expand this how do I build two more
geographic areas how do I expand my
product reach how do I add more features
how do I create more services how do I
add a premium line or a budget line
right how do I go beyond my state or my
province or my country or how do I build
this thing out you need to think about
how am I gonna extend my product line
and a lot of it will come from your
customers again this is just adjusting
to what the market wants you will find
that your customers will take you places
that you never even thought of again the
success in business comes from combining
what there's a need for what customers
want and what you're passionate about
creating so as you get out into the
market one of the best things you can do
is get us close to your customers as
possible it doesn't make financial sense
if you're selling a twenty dollar
product to call each customer and ask
how they're using it but it's so
important to do because it's gonna give
you the feedback on how you can get
better
how you can improve your product to
better serve their needs but also how
you can extend it because the more you
understand their use the more you
understand their lives the more you
understand their business the more
you're going to come up with other
creative solutions that you can sell
into them and then you can sell to a
broader market as well the way to expand
business an easy fast simple way to do
it is to talk to every single customer
understand why they bought it understand
how they're using it and then thinking
about how you can expand your market
based on what your customers need or
asking for and you have a creative
solution for number six is building a
team this is another stumbling block
that a lot of entrepreneurs fall back on
so you had some success you built your
first product you're getting some
results from it you're expanding you're
building other products at some point
that becomes a huge crush on your time
it's like you can't do more physically
you just don't have the time you're
maxed out this happens quite early on
for a lot of entrepreneurs you're maxed
out and so to be able to build the
multi-million dollar company or getting
your first million you need to build a
team you got to bring people on board
you got to bring on people to help you
get it to the next step even if it
starts off part-time you know my first
guy was one hour a day starting off
part-time moving up moving up moving up
moving up to allow you to focus on the
higher picture things for your business
here's what happens in a lot of
companies you have some success you
realize you want to build a team you
hire somebody great your first hire
doesn't work out usually the first hire
I won't work out because you suck as a
leader you suck as a manager and you
don't know how to hire people and that
makes sense if this is the first time
you've done it don't expect to bring on
a star employee the first time through
as you work through that process you
learn how to be a better manager you
learn how to be a better leader you
learn how to improve your process so
that you bring on better people to start
with but what happens to a lot of people
is they didn't get their first hire
right and then they crouch practice and
you know what
I can't work with other people I just
have to do it all myself and you can be
really successful make a couple hundred
thousand dollars a year as a solo
consultant if you're one of the best at
what you do in the world but you don't
see a lot of million dollar consultants
a year or a few but a solo million
dollar consultants a year you don't
really see that happen those guys have a
team and you need to start to build your
team you want to hit a million dollars
you need to start building your team to
allow you to focus on the higher
leverage things and expect to make
mistakes with your first team members
expect to hire the wrong people expect
them to make mistakes
expect for you to work on yourself to
get better as a leader manager recruiter
so you bring the right people on board
because you need to figure out this
piece if you're going off and accomplish
big things a number seven is leaving the
team so we've hired our first person now
we're gonna bring on more people and
more people and more people and quickly
what you realize in a bigger company is
your highest leverage skill is going to
be getting the most out of your team
instead of the productive work that you
do in your business so let me explain
when you're first starting off you're
doing everything your value is a hundred
percent of the business when you hire
somebody new to take on a new role you
might be both working the same number of
hours but you're maybe adding more value
because you're the CEO you're the
founder but let's say it's like forty
percent then sixty percent you or 70
percent you thirty percent then great as
you add more people though your
percentage keeps coming down you may be
the single most important person in the
business but collectively your team is
doing way more than you are if I look at
this business with this YouTube channel
we've got eight people working on making
this channel happen for you guys every
single day I contribute the most value
sorry guys on my team but I don't do
like collectively and my team does way
more than I do because I can't do all
this stuff myself and so understanding
that you need to not just focus on what
you are contributing to the business
your day to day tasks and activities but
your most important activity is building
up the people on your team because if
they get better your company gets way
way way better as you continue to build
your team your value in terms of the
tasks you provide become decreasing ly
and decreasing ly important because your
team takes over much more the enterprise
and so shifting your priorities of
focusing on your team and building them
up
will have a much bigger impact to help
you get to not just a million dollars
but way through it too so those are my
thoughts on the seven stages that
startups go through to make their first
million I love to know what do you guys
think what point resonated the most with
you what do you need to work on the most
to help you break that barrier and am I
missing an 8 9 10 that you guys want to
add to the list share some love I'd love
to hear from you down the comments and
fellow people a believed nation thank
you guys so much for watching I believe
in you hope you continue to believe in
yourself
and whatever your one where it is much
love see you soon